now to another effort to help las vegas
in need delivering with dignity is
looking for volunteers right now ahead
of the holiday season
joining us is casey noble coordinator
with the program
thanks so much for joining us casey
first off tell us what delivery with
dignity is and how it was created
yes so delivering with dignity is a
covered response initiative
that was started back in march of this
year at the request
of county commissioner marilyn
kirkpatrick
what we're able to do is provide
restaurant quality prepared meals
to the clients that we serve the goal
was to keep our
vulnerable individuals and families at
home
while keeping the rest of the community
safe in addition to that we've been able
to support our independently owned
restaurant partners by
keeping 57 of their restaurant workers
employed this year wow that is
considerable and
i bet the need is so great this year
what do you need right now
to keep the organization going and so
you can help these families
so our volunteer food heroes are the
life of our organization since march
they have helped us safely deliver
nearly 250 000 meals across the valley
five days a week we deliver to about 200
households a day
meeting on average 30 volunteers a day
we saw an amazing turnout during the
week of thanksgiving
next week the need is going to be just
as high
as we approach the new year that needs
only going to continue as well
in addition to volunteers donations help
to keep our program running
this program was intended to be a
short-term program but
as the need has continued to increase as
a result
of the vulnerable members of our
community continuing to stay at home
now if one of our viewers needs
assistance how can they qualify casey
to qualify for our program you have to
meet our triple threat most vulnerable
criteria
what that means is you are at the
highest risk of exposure to covid per
the cdc guidelines
you may not have access to resources
whether that be your family
friends a church or another non-profit
here in town
and additionally you don't have the
financial means to provide meals for
yourself
the more information can be found at our
deliveringwithdignitylv.org website
where viewers can inquire and submit a
contact form to see if they qualify
casey thank you so much for your efforts
and your time today
i know you said you started in march you
didn't know it would last this long but
of course it will be continuing
into the new year and um thank you again
for all you do
and the efforts thank you and have a
safe holiday thank you as well